the Joe Rogan experience oh yeah Robin
that's amazing yeah but he got the worst
movie ever patch Adams that has to be a
joke like patch Adams you've seen patch
Adams I didn't watch I mean I probably
did at the time but I don't remember it
it's I don't remember the premise it's
something really ridiculous like a clown
that works with cancer patients or
something something along those lines
yeah yeah no he was he was a doctor who
would who would use Khan was based on a
real true story would you say Jim yes
yeah it was a doctor who would come in
and do silly things to make the patients
laugh to try and help their spirits yeah
but it was bad because they all died
anyway yeah but they died with great
spirit mmm it was a really happy death
they had he was a rough one man when
that guy hung himself well yeah you know
I never got to meet him I met him once
at the improv was crazy I didn't know I
was meeting him until like five minutes
into the conversation I realized it was
Robin Williams how long ago was that
years ago obviously he's dead yeah so
not I'm not racing no I don't remember
but I did a show at the improv it was
quite a few years ago I was it was
during the time of the podcast I did
show at the improv and then afterwards
I'm shaking hands with people and taking
pictures and this very slight older man
with a beard a heavy beard wearing a
baseball hat comes up and he's like
really complimentary but he obviously
knows a lot about stand-up he's asking
me questions about writing and questions
about you know like certain bits like a
really laughing and and then I'm like
holy [ __ ]
this is Robin Williams yeah like I was
like oh thanks man I really appreciate
that's really cool and like I just think
he's some cool guy and I realized in the
middle of the conversation this is Robin
[ __ ] Williams yeah because he's gonna
hit this crazy thick ass white beard hey
you guys grew a real bushy beard I think
he was hidin man you know I think for a
lot of folks that are like real
sensitive and he's obviously a real
sensitive guy that that place of being
that famous is [ __ ] overwhelming that
famous and known for whether you are or
not but
you're known for being always like on
yeah and then there's the pressure of
having to be on now so you don't
disappoint the illusion
yeah and that's got to be [ __ ] taxing
it's gotta be always on and then just
also you know it's just thus just the
pressure of everyone recognizing you
everywhere you go
[Applause]